es gibt einen neuen streitpunkt corona
einige in der union sagen es gibt jetzt
eben kein geld mehr für die grundrente
herr bosbach hat die grundrente noch
eine chance
ja ich bin aus überzeugung aus
sachlichen gründen für die grundrente
obwohl ich die beiden hauptprobleme
kenne einmal finanzierung durch an
steueraufkommen einer steuerart die es
noch gar nicht gibt und ich weiß auch
nicht ob diese steuer jemals tatsächlich
erhoben wird wenn der hochfrequenzhandel
davon gar nicht betroffen wird und das
andere argument ist er
ordnungspolitische natur wir haben die
beitragsfinanzierte rente und wir haben
die bedürfnisorientierte grundsicherung
trotzdem wäre auch corona für mich kein
grund die grundrente aufzuschieben
und zwar aus den ganz persönlichen
erfahrungen die ich in 23 jahren
bundestag und bürgersprechstunden
gesammelt haben bei mir sind sehr sehr
viele bürgerinnen und bürger gewiss ich
schätze mal 80 über 80 prozent waren es
frauen die ein langes erwerbsleben
hatten kinder erzogen haben oder
angehörige gepflegt haben und eine ganz
niedrige rente und wenn ich dann gesagt
habe es ja möglicherweise ein anspruch
auf ergänzende sozialhilfe auf
grundsicherung dann kann die frage was
muss ich dafür tun
da musste ich dann sagen ja dafür müssen
sie aber zum sozialamt gehen
in fast allen fällen haben die
betroffenen gesagt ich habe in meinem
leben keine sozialhilfe bezogen oder
kein hartz iv ich möchte auch im alter
nicht darauf angewiesen sein
danke dass sie mir geholfen haben und
sind gegangen das hat mir immer von
herzen leid getan
und wer über drei jahrzehnte gearbeitet
hat kinder erzogen angehörige gepflegt
hat dem sollten wir den gang ins
sozialamt ersparen und das hat mit
corona überhaupt nichts zu tun